Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Wir wollen heute sprechen über die 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Da ist wieder so einiges passiert. Bisschen was an der Tabellenspitze. Heute geht es aber eher um das untere Gefilde der Tabelle. Erklär ich euch gleich hier in Rasenfunk Kurzpass 261. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Schön, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt zum Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Wir wollen uns mal wieder mit der 2. Bundesliga der Männer auseinandersetzen. Denn die hört ja irgendwie nicht auf Geschichten zu produzieren und die wollen wir hier abbilden. Mein Name ist Max Jakob-Ost, ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf mastodon.social und ich begrüße heute bei mir eine tolle Runde. Ich freue mich sehr, dass sie alle hier sind. Zum einen haben wir hier eigentlich ein Kollegen-Duell, ne, eine Kollegen-Kooperation. Zum einen ist Fadi Keblawi da von den Nürnberger Nachrichten. Der Ed Gopeng hörst auf Twitter und man kann ihn auch hören im KDEP Podcast. Hallo Fadi, schön, dass du wieder hier bist. Guten Tag, hallo, ich freue mich. Ich freue mich ebenso. Michael Fischer ist nämlich auch hier, auch von den Nürnberger Nachrichten und vom 4. Flachpass, dementsprechend auch als Flachpass-Unterstrich, auf Twitter zu finden. Siehst du, wie leicht das jetzt mir von der Lippe geht? Michi, du hast alles richtig gemacht. Danke, dass du dich umbenannt hast und schön, dass du hier bist. Ja, sehr gut. Das ist schön, dass ihr nicht nur hier mit dabei seid, sondern zum Teil auch aktive Hörer seid. Und ich glaube, das können wir auch über Louis Loeser sagen. Er ist unter anderem Fanradio- und Blindenreporter beim SV Sandhausen, dementsprechend auch der Experte zum SVS. Er ist der Ad-Regionalkapital auf Twitter. Hallo Louis, schön, dass du mal wieder hier bist.
Hallo Max und ich freue mich, dass ich diese fränkische Runde ergänzen darf, denn ich schalte mich aus Bayreuth dazu. Also grüße aus Oberfranken.
Es ist ja ein absoluter Traum. Also vom Proporz her bekommt Michael Söder Freudentränen in den Augen, wie das hier aufgeteilt ist. Und ich sitze ja in München. Also eine bayerische Runde. Hört aber bitte trotzdem weiter, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Bitte verwendet es nicht gegen uns. Wir wollen auf die zweite Liga blicken. Vorher möchte ich aber natürlich noch loswerden, dass der Rasenfunk nur durch euch möglich ist, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer da draußen. Der Rasenfunk finanziert sich ausschließlich über euch. Wir zahlen unsere Gästen ein Honorar. Noch ist es ein bisschen zu klein, meinem Empfinden nach. Und auch mein Lebensunterhalt bezieht sich aus dem Rasenfunk. Aber um den geht es jetzt gar nicht vorrangig. Auf rasenfunk.de slash supporters club könnt ihr uns unterstützen. Und wir würden uns sehr freuen, wenn ihr das tut. Wenn ihr euch einfach überlegt, was haben diese Sendungen für euch für einen Gegenwert. Also ist das irgendwie ein kleiner Kaffee im Monat oder ein Kinobesuch im Monat. Und das kann man ja auch tun, wenn man nur zum Beispiel diese Zweitliga-Kurzpässe hört, weil man sich vielleicht aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht für die erste Liga interessiert. Also bitte geht mal in euch, ob ihr uns unterstützen wollt. Unter rasenfunk.de slash supporters club erfahrt ihr, wie das geht. Jetzt blicken wir auf die Liga. Und erstmal müssen wir so ein bisschen aufarbeiten, was da so passiert ist in den letzten zwei Wochen. Wir haben unter anderem ein Hamburger Derby gesehen, das mit Ereignisreich vielleicht ganz gut umschrieben ist. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wer von euch beginnen möchte, Michael, vielleicht, dass du mal als erster anfängst. Wir haben aber auch gesehen, dass der HSV danach verloren hat. Und die Frage, die mir sogar HSV-Fans gestellt haben, ist, verkacken die es schon wieder? Ja doch, eigentlich genauso wird einem die Frage gestellt. Wie blickst du denn auf das, was da jetzt so an der Tabellenspitze passiert ist?
Die Antwort ist ja. Ich habe mittlerweile wieder das Gefühl, es ist zu viel HSV. Ich war schon wieder passiert. Und auch dieser bestimmte, der versucht hat, das wegzudiskutieren. Ich habe letztens ein Interview gesehen, ich glaube, es war Schotlau, der sagte, nein, das ist uns alles scheißegal, was da diskutiert wird. Und das schaffen wir auf jeden Fall. Allen anscheinend nach schaffen sie es ja auf jeden Fall schon mal nicht. Weil ich bin, wenn wir gleich springen, auch sicher, dass die oberen beiden das schaffen. Das heißt, HSV wird auf jeden Fall Relegation spielen. Und das ist in den letzten Jahren nicht allzu erfolgreich war, hat man gesehen. Aber vielleicht hat man es auch nicht anders verdient, wenn man gegen den 1. FC Magdeburg, der nicht hoch genug gelobt werden kann für seinen spielerischen Ansatz. Aber wenn man da zweimal in der Saison 3-2 verliert als Aufstiegskandidat, wenn man da die Unterschiede kennt monetär alleine, dass man da zweimal verliert, gibt es auch andere Aufstiegsanwärter, die zweimal gegen den 1. FC Nürnberg verloren haben. Es gibt Aufstiegsanwärter, die gegen die Spielvereinigung Grötter Viert nur einen Punkt geholt haben. Also da gibt es einige Vereine, die es schon auch verdient haben, nicht aufzusteigen und andere haben es eben dann doch mehr verdient, aufzusteigen vielleicht.
Habe ich da einen Konsens hier in der Runde, Fadi? Also die anderen sind natürlich Darmstadt und Heidenheim, die haben beide ihre Spiele gewonnen seit der letzten Ligatur. Das Tabellenbild ist 64 Punkte Darmstadt, 60 Heidenheim. Und dann haben wir eben schon eine Vier-Punkte-Lücke auf die 56 Punkte des HSV.
Ja, natürlich haben wir da einen Konsens, wie wer bin ich, um Michael Fischer zu untersprechen. Ich glaube auch, es wird maximal die Relegation für den HSV. Ich glaube nicht, dass sich da dann ein Erstligist findet, der keine Antwort auf den Walther Ball weiß. Deshalb, sie schaffen es diesmal eben in die Relegation und scheitern da. Ich bin die ganze Zeit überlegen, welcher Aufstiegsanwärter zweimal gegen den 1. FC Nürnberg verloren hat. Aber gut, das ist jetzt erstmal nicht das Thema. Es ist ein bisschen schade für den HSV, so unsympathisch man diesen Trainer finden kann. Er hat immerhin eine Idee vom Fußball, was man nicht über alles sagen kann in dieser Liga. Das ist so ein bisschen das Einzige, was mich da etwas traurig stimmt mit Blick auf den HSV. Dass diese Idee jetzt eben auch wieder zerschellt am System 2. Liga. Über das ich diesmal gar nicht so viel schimpfen will, weil da habe ich beim letzten Mal hier schlechte Erfahrungen.
Du bindest das Feedback mit ein. Michael, willst du auflösen gegen wen? Welche Aufstiegsanwärter verloren hat? Bielefeld geht es aber nicht, oder?
Fortuna Düsseldorf. Aufstiegsanwärter habe ich ja gesagt nicht. Ach ja, stimmt. Fortuna Düsseldorf hat sogar dreimal gegen den HSV Nürnberg verloren, wie Fadi Weis in Pokalia auch noch.
Ein Lieblingsgegner des Ersten.
Fortuna und St. Pauli und Paderborn, aber auch alle mit 50 Punkten, 6 Punkte hinter den HSV. Louis, kommt da noch jemand ran von den hinteren Plätzen deiner Meinung nach?
Ja, ich hatte eigentlich Paderborn nach dem Spiel gegen Sandhausen schon abgeschrieben, hatte gesagt, so, damit war es das dann mit dem Aufstieg. Aber der HSV könnte sie ja jetzt wieder reinholen. Am Freitag gibt es ja das direkte Duell. Also, wenn da der HSV nochmal federn lässt, dann ist da vielleicht auch nochmal was drin. Aber so rein realistisch sehe ich auch einfach – also, ich sehe ehrlich gesagt nicht, wie sich da noch viel an diesem Top 3 ändert. Und ich glaube auch, dass der HSV in die Relegation geht, um mich da mal, um den allgemeinen Chor anzuschließen. Was Michi gemeint hat, ich finde auch, dass der HSV so ein bisschen – also, das hat mir auch schon diese Wuschkubitsch-Geschichte gesehen, da will ich jetzt aber auch gar nicht mehr groß drüber reden – aber dass man sich so ein bisschen dieses Lagerdenken, so ein bisschen nach außen abschottet. Tim Walther hat jetzt auch noch mal auf der PK gestern gesagt, ihm interessiert nicht, was von außen herangetragen wird. Er ist da 100 Prozent überzeugt. Und ich weiß nicht, ob das dann manchmal wirklich nur Selbstvertrauen ist oder ob es dann teilweise fast schon an Arroganz oder Unbelehrbarkeit grenzt. Auch so eine Aussage wie nach dem KSC-Spiel, die unsere Kritiker ja nicht wissen, ist, dass wir ja nächstes Jahr gar nicht mehr in dieser Liga spielen. Also ich glaube, da sind viele Aussagen dabei gewesen, die ihn später vielleicht so ein bisschen jagen werden.
Das kennt man von Tim Walther natürlich gar nicht.
Ja, deswegen, ich bin mal gespannt. Aber ich würde es natürlich wünschen, dass es noch ein spannenderes Aufstiegsrennen gibt. Ich sehe es aber gerade noch nicht so ganz, mal gucken. Also am ehesten, wenn Paderborn jetzt eben dieses direktige Duell gewinnt, dann könnte es noch mal ein bisschen spannend werden da oben drin. Aber die haben eben auch gezeigt, dass sie dann wieder gegen Sandhausen, ein Spiel, was sie eigentlich schon längst hätten schließen können, also dass Sandhausen dann 2-0 aufholt. Gab es, glaube ich, drei Jahre lang nicht mehr. Paderborn hat es geschafft, dass der SVS auch diese Serie dann mal beendet hat.
Ich will ein bisschen aus dem Konsens ausbrechen. Bisher hatten wir immer dramatische Saisonfinals, und das wird auch in dieser Spielzeit kommen. Und ich würde mich noch gar nicht festlegen, dass Heidenheim mit den vier Punkten vom HSV weg ist. Und Tim Walter zu den Aussagen – also man kann natürlich über seine öffentliche Darstellung und so weiter eine Meinung haben, das ist relativ einfach. Ich finde aber auch, dass die HSV-Trainer im Grunde schon seit ein paar Jahren in der Situation sind. Was sollen sie denn sagen? Wenn sie sagen, ich habe auch Angst, dass wir jetzt im April alles verlieren, dann sagen die Leute, guck mal, sogar der Trainer zweifelt. Wenn sie sagen, ach was, das wird alles gut werden, sagen die Leute, ja, der hat ja noch keine Ahnung, was auf ihn zukommt, und es wird doch eh schiefgehen. Also ich finde, das ist auch eher ein undankbarer Job in der Außendarstellung. Naja, wenn wir bei undankbaren Jobs sind, dann können wir jetzt auch einfach über die Spielvereinigung Grotte Fürth und so ein bisschen den Abstiegskampf reden. Das war eine etwas erzwungene Überleitung. Ich gebe es ja zu, denn es gibt ja immerhin viele Geschichten, die man als Fürth-Reporter zu erzählen hat. Also wir springen in die untere Tabellenhälfte. Da beginnen wir mit KSC und Magdeburg, die sind mit 39 und 38 Punkten im Grunde jetzt langsam raus aus dem Abstiegskampf, denn das sind 9 bzw. 10 Punkte Vorsprung auf Tabellenplatz 16. Müssen wir die Spielvereinigung, die 36 Punkte hat, damit 7 Punkte Vorsprung, müssen wir die noch dazuzählen zum Abstiegskampf, Michi?
Als Berufspessimist würde ich sagen ja, aber sie haben alle Chancen am Freitagabend in Bielefeld, das tatsächlich aus eigener Kraft zu schaffen. Und wenn sie da gewinnen würden, hätten sie den sogenannten Klassen halt auch sicher. Aber wenn man sich die Auswärtstabelle anschaut, kann man eigentlich fast davon ausgehen, dass sie da nicht gewinnen werden. Deshalb würde ich sie da noch mit rein zählen. Aber Alexander Zorniger, der Coach, den haben wir ja auch schon mal erwähnt hier, als ein oder andere Mal, ist sich sicher, dass sie noch den einen oder anderen Punkt, den sie noch brauchen, Zitat, holen werden. Ich habe mal vor einigen Tagen den beliebten Kickertabellenrechner angeworfen und wenn die Spielfeinde noch einen Punkt aus vier Spülen holt, dann wird sie maximal 15. Also es sollte sich ganz gut ausgehen, aber es ist natürlich auch jetzt nicht das Ziel eines Vereins, der aus der Bundesliga abgestiegen ist, bis zum letzten Spieltag, um den Liga-Verbleib zu spielen. Aber über die Ziele und Ansprüche in Fürth habe ich in den letzten Wochen sehr viele Diskussionen geführt.
Also wir sehen schon zum einen, dieser Freitagabend wird wirklich interessant. Bielefeld Fürth und Hamburg Paderborn, beides könnten quasi schon so vorenseidende Spiele sein. Ja, dann lass doch da mal ein bisschen tiefer reingehen, weil die Saison, also wir haben schon häufiger über Fürth gesprochen, sie haben sich ja auch unbedingt aufdrängen wollen, mit Trainerwechseln und so weiter. Und das letzte Mal, als wir gesprochen haben, war aber Alexander Zorninger, glaube ich, noch gar nicht so lange im Amt. Kann man denn jetzt schon ein bisschen mehr Aussagen oder klarere Aussagen treffen, was dieser Trainerwechsel bewirkt hat?
Nicht so lange im Amt, das ist gut. Also wir haben ja in der Winterpause gesprochen, in der großen Folge mit Tim und Eva. Tatsächlich, ich habe ja gehört, das ist das Mainz-Phänomen. Fürth ist überregional nicht von Belang, so ungefähr. Habe ich ja in einer Rasenfunk-Folge auch mal vernommen. Da passiert nicht genug bei diesem Verein.
Ist das so? Habe ich eine Erinnerungslücke, aber egal.
In einem früheren Kurzpass wurde das erwähnt. Du siehst, ich bin ein stolzer und treuer Hörer dieses Podcasts. Nein, also es ist tatsächlich so, dass die Spielverhandlungen lange unspektakulär gespielt hat. Also man hat diese vier Spiele vor der Winterpause, es waren die ersten vier von Alexander Zorniger. Die erste Geschichte, die man erzählen kann, ist, dass hier am Freitagabend das erste Spiel sich jährt, zumindest ein Jubiläum ist. Das erste Spiel von Zorniger war auch gegen Bielefeld. Das hat man gewonnen, dann hat man dreimal in Folge 1-0 gewonnen und dann noch in Darmstadt unentschieden gespielt. Das heißt, man hatte zehn Punkte aus vier Spielen vor der Winterpause und hat sich dadurch aus dieser misslichen Lage vom Tabellenplatz 18 wieder hochgearbeitet. Ja, und dann haben wir damals gedacht, ja, das wird ja alles total gut. Und das wurde auch in den Wochen nach der Podcastaufnahme noch gut. Die Klassiker hat unter anderem Testspiele gewonnen, auch in Hoffenheim. Louis kennt diesen Verein, der gut 13-0 geführt hat in dem Testspiel angeblich, war unter Ausschuss der Öffentlichkeit. Angeblich ging es 3 zu 3 aus. Aber dann irgendwie ist dann in dieser langen WM-Pause irgendwas passiert. Also weil im Trainingslager die Testspiele waren schon nicht mehr so gut. Man hat auch dann die Generalprobe, die sogenannte Vor-dem-Saison-Start gegen den österreichischen Zweitligisten Linz, gar nicht überzeugend gespielt. Dann aber wieder in Kiel am ersten Rückrundenspieltag ein sehr überzeugendes Spiel gemacht und dachte, jeder gut, die gewinnen da jetzt 3-4 Null in Kiel und haben dann aber verloren. Und das war die erste Niederlage unter Zorniger. Und für mich ist das so ein bisschen so ein Bruch in dieser Saison, weil danach gab es irgendwie kein Spiel mehr, das so wirklich gut war. Also Fadi erinnert sich, wir waren gemeinsam beim Franken-Turbi in der Woche danach. Das war von beiden Vereinen fußballerisch nun nicht ganz so gut. Von dem Spiel fand ich noch ein bisschen besser als vorm ersten FC Nürnberg. Man hat dieses Derby ja auch gewonnen. Und dann in den Wochen danach kann man schon ganz klare Muster erkennen. Also man muss ja nun mal die Heim- und Außerspiele anschauen. Unter Alexander Zorniger hat man eigentlich bis zum vergangenen Wochenende jedes Heimspiel bis auf eines gegen Hannover gewonnen. Also sechs von sieben Heimspielen gewonnen. Hat jetzt dann gegen Heidenheim verloren. Über das Wie kann man noch sprechen. Aber dass man zuhause extrem stark ist, auch zumindest den Ergebnissen nach. Es gab dann auch nicht viele Spiele, die wirklich überzeugend gerieten. Magdeburg fragt sich wahrscheinlich jetzt noch, wie sie 3-0 in Fürth verlieren konnten. Oder Jan, der 2-1 verlor in Fürth, der war in erster Halbzeit auch ziemlich gut vor einigen Wochen. Aber in diesem Heimspiel hat man sich die Punkte geholt, die man braucht. Aber auswärts ist es unerklärlich. Auch nach diesem Derby beim 1. FC Nürnberg, das Spiel in Karlsruhe, war ich vor Ort, das war grauenhaft anzuschauen von Fürth. Alexander Zorniger hat zum ersten Mal seine Mannschaft wirklich krass öffentlich kritisiert. Und das ist ja was, was man auch von ihm kennt aus früheren Jahren. Es gibt auf Twitter auch diesen Account AngryZorniger, der sich auch gerne mal drüber lustig macht, dass es der Anfang vom Ende ist, wenn Alexander Zorniger öffentlich über seine Spieler herzieht. Ich hatte schon ein bisschen Angst, weil er das schon im Februar gemacht hat. Aber das tut Fürth, finde ich, aber gut. Also nicht nur aus Reporter-Sicht, sondern auch aus Vereinssicht. Weil diesem Verein lange schon sehr vieles sehr positiv gesehen wurde. Also auch in der Vorrunde hat man dann immer nach dem 2-2 in Regensburg, nach dem 1-1 gegen Sandhausen – no front, Louis – gesagt, ja, ist schon okay, man hat ja einen Punkt geholt immerhin, und das ist ja okay. Man ist halt ein Bundesliga-Absteiger, da müsste man heimspiel gegen Sandhausen schon gewinnen eigentlich. Und Alexander Zorniger spricht das eben schonungslos an, weil er so ein ambitionierter Trainer ist. Und weil er aber halt auch einfach so ärgert sich ist, dass er jedes Spiel gewinnen will. Und das sieht man auch, dieses Training ist sehr gut, aber offenbar ist diese Mannschaft, ich weiß nicht, ob es charakterlich ist, mental, psychisch, ist irgendwie nicht gefestigt genug, um auch auswärts irgendwelche Widerständen zu trotzen. Also man hat ja auswärts sehr viele Spiele verloren, eigentlich fast alle, bis auf das Spiel in Sandhausen. Und nach dem Spiel in Rostock hat Alexander Zorniger ja sogar von einem massiven Ausfall aller Systeme gesprochen. Und das ist ja schon eine vernichtende Kritik an seiner Mannschaft, weil da wirklich gar nichts funktioniert hat. Man hätte in Rostock vor einigen Wochen die Möglichkeit gehabt, die Punkte 37, 38 und 39 zu holen. Das heißt, dann wäre man mit Sicherheit durch gewesen. Weil dann wären wir in dieser Riege von den Magdeburgs, die du vorhin erwähnt hast, Max. Und jetzt muss man halt irgendwie schauen, dass man nochmal diese ein, zwei Punkte holt, die man eben noch braucht, um sicher durch zu sein. Aber ich bin mir sicher, dass es da im Sommer nochmal einen großen Neuanfang braucht. Weil die jüngsten Wortmeldungen von Alexander Zorniger lassen schon tief blicken, dass er jetzt auch nicht mehr allzu optimistisch ist, was diese Saisonfinale hier angeht.
Also vorletzter ist man tatsächlich in der Auswärtstabelle. Nur neun Punkte von insgesamt 36 hat man auswärts geholt. Unter anderem, Louis, beim SV Sandhausen. War vielleicht auch einfach der SVS zu stark? Ich frage es einfach mal so, wie es wahrscheinlich ja war.
Zu stark? Zu stark vor allen Dingen, ja. Ich finde es vor allem witzig, dass ich hier eingerahmt werde von der gesamten Thomas-Oral-Amtszeit. Einmal Start in Nürnberg und dann Schluss gegen Fürth. Ja, stimmt. Das war dann auch eins von den beiden Spielen, die Präsident Mach Mayer als Totalausfall genannt hat bei der Pressemeldung, warum letztlich Thomas-Oral gehen musste. Und ich glaube, über das Hinspiel Michi, da konnten wir dann ja schon in Persona drüber reden. Da hat sich die Spielvereinigung ja auch so ein bisschen selbst ins Bein geschossen. Das hat mich jetzt auch beim Heidenheim-Spiel ein bisschen wieder dran erinnert, weil beim Heidenheim-Spiel hat man ja auch quasi zwei Tore sich einfach selbst eingeschränkt durch Ballverluste im Spielaufbau. Gegen Sandhausen war es dann Ballverlust nach einem Einwurf in der eigenen Hälfte. Also, ja, ich glaube, Sandhausen-Spiele waren in dieser Saison auch ganz besonders beiführt, in beide Richtungen.
Also man muss schon sagen, dieses Spiel in Sandhausen, weil Louis es gerade angesprochen hat, das war von Fürth in der ersten Halbzeit ein richtig überzeugender Auftritt. Also es war für mich eigentlich fast die beste Halbzeit in dieser Saison, weil man eben diese Verunsicherung, die spürbar und greifbar war in diesem Stadion und auch diese Angst zu verlieren, sowohl auf wie neben dem Platz einfach ausgenutzt hat, hat zwei frühe Tore geschossen, hat nach 26 Minuten 2-0 geführt. Und da war für mich – Schande auf mich – aber war für mich klar, dass der SV Sandhausen absteigen wird nach diesem Spiel. Er hat uns eines Besseren belehrt, und wird uns auch eines Besseren noch belehren, bin ich sicher. Aber das war von Fürth'er Seite ein gutes Spiel, aber auch wieder nur über eine Halbzeit. Die zweite Halbzeit hat man dann in einem gewissen Kontrollmodus, sagt Alexander Zorniger, runtergespielt. Man hat auch niemanden nicht mehr viel zugelassen. Aber man könnte sich ja auch mal ein bisschen Selbstvertrauen holen. So blöd das klingt, ob man den Gegner 4-0 abschließt. Das machen andere Mannschaften ja auch. ZDFZ St. Pauli hat ja, glaube ich, zwei Wochen zuvor 5-0 gewonnen in Sandhausen. Das wäre in diesem Spiel auch locker möglich gewesen. Und diese individuellen Aussätze sind schon ein großes Problem in Fürth. Also man lässt nicht viele Tore zu. Alexander Zorniger ist ja auch ein Statistik- und Datenfreund. Max, du wirst wahrscheinlich gleich sagen, dass das alles gar nicht stimmt. Aber er hat gesagt, dass zum Beispiel die Expected Goals against gar nicht so schlimm sind, dass man da so weit unten stehen müsste. Oder man auch die Chancenqualität der Gegner ist meistens einfach nicht so gut. Also auch wenn dann nichts dabei rauskommt manchmal und dann eben auch das nicht reinzelt in die Expected Goals. Aber der Gegner ist nicht so gefährlich, dass der Fürth jedes Mal besiegen muss. Aber jedes Mal bringt man sich oder fast jedes Mal durch individuelle Aussetzer so krass unter Druck. Also in der Hinrunde war es Max Christianzen nach einem eigenen Einwurf den Ball an Alexander Eswein verliert. Jetzt war es gegen Heidenheim, also Damian Michalski, der – ich weiß nicht, was er macht. Wir haben in der Hinrunde glaube ich oder nach der Hinrunde über ihn gesprochen. Da war er so der beste Zweitliga-Verteidiger nach Patrick Pfeiffer. Ja, jetzt ist er, würde ich mal sagen, nicht mehr der zweitbeste Zweitliga-Verteidiger, um es positiv auszudrücken. Der auch extrem langsam ist, der sich schon viele Fehler geleistet hat in der Rückrunde. Der den Ball einfach aufs eigene Tor schießt. Das war ja nicht mein Ballverlust, wie du gesagt hast, sondern der den Ball einfach, weil er den Laufduell falsch eingeschätzt hat, aufs eigene Tor geschossen. Also wenn ich in der Lage bin, dann dresche ich den Ball über das Tribündach und schieße ihn aufs eigene Tor. Und in der zweiten Halbzeit war es das Gleiche mit Andreas Linde, dem fand ich eigentlich in dem Spiel sehr guten Tor heute, der dann ins Triplen gegen Kleindienst geht. Das würde ich jetzt auch nicht unbedingt machen, wenn man die Torquote und die Formkurve von Tim Kleindienst kennt. Und dann hat man damit eben zwar null verloren, aber auch da hätte man nicht verlieren müssen. Also in diesem Heimspiel hätte man auch einen Punkt mitnehmen können. Also 0-0 oder 1-1 wäre da möglich gewesen. Auch wenn man sagen muss, weil wir vorhin über die Aufsteiger gesprochen haben, die potenziellen Aufsteiger, dass der FC Heidenheim schon sehr routiniert dann auch gespielt hat. Und dass man da einfach sieht, was das ausmacht, wenn eine Mannschaft einen Lauf hat und eine Mannschaft Selbstbewusstsein hat. Ich bin jetzt noch gespannt auf die letzten zwei Saisonspiele der Fürth, weil sie spielen noch beim HSV. Das ist ja auch sehr HSV. Ich habe immer dann die Auswärts-Tabelle der Fürth erkennt, dass man da dann vielleicht nicht gewinnt als HSV gegen Fürth. Es gäbe so viele Geschichten, die noch weiter erzählt werden könnten in der Saison, aber man merkt schon, dass das irgendwie nicht stimmt. Wenn man es auch ein bisschen zu quer liest und auch hört, was im Umfeld des Vereins gesprochen wird, dass Alexander Zorniger mit diesem Kader jetzt auch nicht unbedingt 100 Prozent zufrieden ist, weil es ja doch für einen Fußball zusammengestellt ist, der anders ist, als der den Alexander Zorniger spielt. Es gibt halt Spieler, die sind noch Rautenspieler aus Stefan Leitls Zeiten. Die müssen dann in einer Dreierkette als Schienenspieler ganz hoch pressen. Das ist zum Beispiel das Spiel von Marco Mayhöfer. Der war im Aufstiegsjahr einer der besten Zweitliga-Außenverteidiger. Vielleicht sogar der beste. Jeder auf St. Pauli wird meckern. Es lehrt Pakarada, aber es war für mich auf jeden Fall Marco Mayhöfer. Im Aufstiegsjahr war er extrem gut in dieser Viererkette. Er ist aber kein Schienenspieler in einer Fünferkette. Ich sehe schon Fadis Gesicht, wenn ich das Wort Schienenspieler erwähne. Aber das passt einfach in einigen Dingen nicht zusammen. Aber das wird sich im Sommer weisen. Davon gehe ich mal aus. Die Frage ist, die Vertragssituation lässt es nicht unbedingt zu. Also man müsste schon sehr viel arbeiten im Sommer, damit man einen größeren Umbruch hinkriegt. Und die Verantwortlichen betonen auch, dass der Kader eigentlich gut ist. Der Tabellplatz sagt was anderes.
Wofür dieser Sieg in Rostock so wichtig gewesen wäre, dann hätte man früher in die Planung gehen können. Also ich halte fest, wir haben quasi – die Situation hat sich von der Tabellenkonstellation her beruhigt. Wir können davon ausgehen, Fürth wird da nicht mehr unten reindrutschen. Die Serie von Zorniger ging nicht weiter. Er hatte ja auch umgestellt damals auf Dreier- bzw. Fünferkette. Du hast ja gerade auch nochmal erwähnt. Aber immerhin zu Hause ging sie weiter. Ich glaube, so kann man es zusammenfassen. Gegen Heidenheim kann man ja auch mal zu Hause verlieren. Das heißt, wir haben ja eigentlich eher dann so große Themen in Fürth. Weil du jetzt immer mal wieder auch so Stimmungsthemen angesprochen hast und weil das ja auch durchaus was war, was auch den Zornigerwechsel, also den Wechsel hin zu Zorniger begleitet hat. Was hat sich denn da jetzt verändert in den letzten Monaten? Es klingt, würde ich sagen, jetzt nicht nach 100-prozentigem Sonnenschein-Optimismus.
Also insgesamt ist die Stimmung gegenüber Alexander Zorniger, finde ich, sehr positiv nach allem, was ich so wahrnehme. Also er hat auch in der Winterpause von sich aus das Gespräch mit den Ultras gesucht zum Beispiel. Also er hat die Ultras besucht mit einigen Führungsspielern und mit seinem Co-Trainer Assistenten Jurek Rohrberg, den man hier vielleicht noch von Sky kennt, den er mitgebracht hat. Aber er ist da schon sehr bemüht und er hat auch immer wieder die Ultras hervorgehoben, die Fans, die die positive Stimmung verbreiten im Stadion. Also er spielt das natürlich auch ganz klug, weil er die auf seine Seite zieht. War auch notwendig, hat er vor seinem ersten Spiel gegen Bielefeld so ein kurzes Insta-Video gemacht, wo er gesagt hat, alles was passiert, das ist egal, wir müssen jetzt die Kräfte bündeln, um zu gewinnen. Und dann war schon da im Stadion eine deutlich verbesserte Stimmung zu vernehmen. Und man muss schon auch sagen, wenn die Mannschaft so ein bisschen was anbietet, dann ist das Stadion in Fürth auch wahnsinnig leidenschaftlich, aber es ist schon da. Und vor allem bei diesen Flutlichtspielen war das schon ziemlich gut. Also gegen HSV zum Beispiel war schon eine gute Stimmung im Stadion in der Hinrunde. Und noch bei anderen Spielen, jetzt die zweite Halbzeit gegen Regensburg, wenn sich die Spielfange mal reingearbeitet hat, also reingespielt hat es sich eher weniger in dem Spiel, aber reingearbeitet hat und hat dann das Spiel gewonnen, dann ist schon da auch eine gute Stimmung da. Es gab aber auch schon Spiele, in denen sich Alexander Zorniger mit Fans persönlich angelegt hat. Also er ist schon dabei, so ein bisschen einen Stimmungsumschwung auch herbeizuführen. Er hat auch mehrmals schon betont, dass doch die Menschen der Hauptruine ein bisschen leidenschaftlicher sein sollten. Das hat dann mal jemand gemacht und einen Spieler beschimpft. Dann wurde das ganze Spiel von Alexander Zorniger beschimpft.
Der einzelne Zuschauer.
Ja, das war sogar in mehreren Fernsehzusammenstritten zu sehen. Also er hat offenbar dem Vernehmen nach gefordert, dass Ragnar Acher ausgewechselt werden sollte. Das war beim Spiel gegen Magdeburg. Und dann hat man in der Sportschau zusammenfassend gesehen, dass Alexander Zorniger bei allen Toren nicht in Richtung des Spielfelds gejubelt hat, sondern in Richtung desjenigen Fans, der gepöbelt hat. Ich habe es dir doch gesagt, wir gewinnen dieses Spiel.
Das heißt, er kann sich auch wirklich gut auf das Wesentliche fokussieren aktuell.
Ja, könnte man als unsouverän bezeichnen. Ich fand es gut, weil derjenige Fan danach nicht mehr gepöbelt hat in den Spielen danach.
Ich habe ihn beobachtet.
Also es ist schon deutlich erkennbar, dass er da sehr bemüht ist, im ganzen Verein etwas zu verändern und auch eine positivere Grundstimmung zu schaffen. Aber eine positivere Grundstimmung schafft man nicht, wenn man einfach jedes Auswärtsspiel verliert. Also die Fans, die jede Woche Auswärts fahren, die nach Rostock fahren, 670 Kilometer und dann so einen Auftrittsszenen der Mannschaft, da würde ich schon auch mir verarscht vorkommen. Die Spieler sind halt schön geflogen, sehr nachhaltig, aber die Fans fahren halt dann mit dem Bus 10 Stunden hin oder 8, 9 Stunden, und dann sowas zu sehen. Aber man muss schon sagen, dass die Stimmung sich deutlich verbessert hat. Die war in der Hinterrunde mehrmals am Tiefpunkt angekommen. Das kann man auch ein bisschen historisch erklären, dass diesen Bundesliga-Aufstieg niemand mit erleben konnte. Den hat man ja eigentlich als Fan vor dem Start oder vor dem Fernseher miterlebt. Und dann hat man dieses Bundesliga-Jahr auch erst mal vor dem Fernseher miterlebt. Und dann wurde dieses Bundesliga-Jahr – das haben wir auch zu Genüge hier besprochen – zu einem sehr traurigen und hat dann eigentlich auch nur ein negatives Erlebte. Und dann ging die Hinterrunde weiter und man hat wieder nur ein negatives Erlebte. Und dass dann irgendwann mal nach drei Jahren, den man entweder Corona erlebt hat oder schlechte Fußballspiele erlebt hat und Niederlagen seines Fußballvereins, dass die Stimmung da nicht mehr allzu positiv ist, ist auch klar. Aber man hat es schon geschafft, wieder so einen Stimmungswandel herbeizuführen. Und weil wir ja gerne über Statistiken sprechen in diesem Podcast hier. Auch der Zuschauer-Schnitt ist deutlich gestiegen. Also es ist der drittbeste Zuschauer-Schnitt in der Viertel- oder Zweite-Liga-Geschichte. Sogar besser als der des 1. FC Heidenheim. Das finde ich immer noch überraschend, weil Heidenheim in Vor-Corona-Zeiten nämlich deutlich vor der Spielvereinigung war. Und jetzt hat die Spielvereinigung den 1. FC Heidenheim überholt in der Zuschauertabelle. Also man hat natürlich eine natürliche Limitierung, weil höher als Platz 13 oder 12 kann man nicht kommen, weil das Stadion gar nicht größer ist. Und weil doch viele große Standorte drin sind, aber für Fürths sind so diese knapp 11.000, 11.500 sind schon gut. Also man hatte auch mal früher Heimspiele mit 9.000 Zuschauern. Insofern tut sich schon ein bisschen was. Die Verantwortlichen sagen, das ist ein Marathon und kein Sprint zu höheren Zuschauerzahlen. Aber natürlich ist der größte Indikator, dass mehr Zuschauer kommen, immer der sportliche Erfolg.
Gut, dann werden wir uns doch mal angucken, wie der Umbruch vonstattengeht. Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass wir das nächste Mal auch wieder mehr über Rachel Assouci sprechen werden. Aber ich fand jetzt mal, um quasi die letzten Monate zusammenzufassen für die Hörerinnen und Hörer, den Fokus auf Alexander Zorniger recht passend. Und wenn wir über Trainer sprechen, dann können wir auch über den 1. FC Nürnberg sprechen, Fadi. Denn da hat sich so einiges getan. Allerdings nicht alles davon überraschend, muss man sagen. Denn wir haben auch beim Klub nochmal einen Trainerwechsel erlebt. Dieter Hecking hat jetzt letztlich gesagt, komm, jetzt mach's halt ich. Hat sich denn etwas verändert?
Nicht viel, um ehrlich zu sein. Dieter Hecking hat ja gemeinsam mit Christian Fiel übernommen, nachdem der Klub in Heidenheim untergegangen ist beim 05 und dann die Letzten gemerkt haben, dass Markus Weinzel nicht zu dieser Mannschaft passt, um es mal freundlich auszudrücken. Und die beiden haben dann, also Fiel, Trainer der U23, die sehr schön in Fußball spielt in der Regionalliga Bayern, haben dann versucht, auch bei dieser Mannschaft Fußball spielen zu lassen. Gelingt manchmal, nicht immer, bleibt schwierig bis zum Schluss.
Ok, das heißt, der Kader, der von Dieter Hecking zusammengestellt wurde, ist nicht gut genug zusammengestellt für den Fußball, den Dieter Hecking spielen möchte?
Genau so ist es, ja.
Das ist das Klubbigste, was man seit langem sagen konnte über den Klub.
Ja, genau, das ist das große Problem. Thomas Grietlein, der Aussichtsratsvorsitzender, hat es ja bei der Vorstellungspressekonferenz des Trainers Dieter Hecking auch gesagt, dass der Sportvorstand Dieter Hecking mit diesem Move jetzt all in geht und mehr oder weniger auch der Trainer die Arbeit des Sportvorstands retten muss. Das gelingt nicht wirklich. Es ist immer offensichtlicher, dass sich Hecking und sein Sportdirektor Olaf Rebbe massiv verschätzt haben bei der Zusammenstellung dieser Mannschaft vor der Saison. Darüber haben eben zwei andere Trainer, Robert Klaus und Markus Weinzell, verbraucht. Es kann noch gut ausgehen, aber es wird in Nürnberg sicherlich nach dieser Saison erstmal über den Sportvorstand Dieter Hecking diskutiert werden müssen, auch bei Klassenverbleib. Das ist relativ offensichtlich, auch wenn der Aufsichtsrat Heckings Vertrag erst kürzlich verlängert hat. Was bedeutet kürzlich? Letztes Jahr wurde der verlängert, obwohl es da auch schon Stimmen gab, die gesagt haben, vielleicht noch ein bisschen abwarten und mal gucken. Aber der Aufsichtsrat war überzeugt, dass Dieter Hecking immer noch der richtige Mann am richtigen Ort ist. Ob er selber noch so sieht, weiß ich gar nicht. Ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass er, wenn es gut ausgeht, dann im Sommer sagt, so, das war es dann für mich. Und Nürnberg macht mal den 17. Neuanfang in den letzten fünf Jahren gefühlt.
Okay, da stecken viele Themen drin. Ich glaube aber, dass quasi das Übergeordnete, also Hacking, Rebbe und so weiter, das, glaube ich, wird man nach der Saison, so wie du es ja auch gesagt hast, in Ruhe besprechen können. Lass mal erstmal auf das Sportliche blicken, denn bei Fürth waren wir ja gerade sehr optimistisch. Naja, das wird wahrscheinlich schon klappen. Wie optimistisch bist du denn für den Club, der zwar nur einen Platz hinter Fürth liegt, nämlich auf Platz 13, aber ja drei Punkte weniger hat. Das heißt, vier Punkte Vorsprung auf den Relegationsplatz, fünf Punkte im Grunde auf Rang 18, weil es ist sehr, sehr gestaucht unten drin. Man spielt noch gegen Lautern zu Hause, gegen Rostock zu Hause und dann in Magdeburg und am letzten Spieltag in Paderborn. Was ist so dein Gefühl für diese letzten vier Spiele?
Ja, kein eindeutiges. Nach dem Spiel gegen Fortuna Düsseldorf, als der Club tatsächlich eine überraschend gute erste Halbzeit gespielt hat, haben wir bei uns im Podcast den Klassenverbleib schon verkündet. Und dass das jetzt safe ist, vor allem mit Blick auf die graupen Gegner, die da noch kommen im Restprogramm. Der erste graupen Gegner, Hannover 96, hat dann gleich mal lockerflockig 3-0 gegen den Club gewonnen. Also das nehmen wir mal zurück. Ich bin trotzdem noch so einigermaßen optimistisch gerade mit Blick auf die beiden Heimspiele, weil tatsächlich im Max-Morlock-Stadion der Club zuletzt immer besser ausgesehen hat als in fremden Stadien, wo die Bilanz ja ungefähr Spielvereinigung Fürth-mäßig ist. Ein Punkt besser ist der Club in der Auswärtstabelle. Aber die beiden Heimspiele sollten schon dazu beitragen, dass es sich dann gut ausgeht in dieser Saison.
Das wäre allerdings jetzt auch nicht so komplett unklubbig, wenn genau das nicht passieren würde.
Selbstverständlich.
Also ohne, dass ich jetzt trinken will oder so.
Ne, ne. Die Katastrophe muss man in Nürnberg und bei diesem Verein immer mitdenken. Also das ist traditionell hier so. Die Stimmung rund um den Club ist wieder einigermaßen gut seit dem Hacking und vier übernommen haben. Also die war ja nach diesem Spiel in Heidenheim kam es ja so ein bisschen zur Eskalation mit der organisierten Fanszene und so, dass dann Dieter Hecking sich angeblich auch auf der Rückfahrt aus Heidenheim dann gedacht hat, okay, das geht nicht mit Weinziel weiter. Und seitdem ist es zumindest so, dass die Ultras diese Restsaison einigermaßen wohlwollend begleiten, also ohne große Unmutbekundungen, zwar auch mit einem optischen Boykott, also es gibt keine Fahnen und Transparente derzeit, aber ansonsten wohlwollend und auch der Rest des Publikums. Man merkt es dann in so Spielen wie gegen Düsseldorf, dass in Nürnberg wirklich schon sehr, sehr kleine Dinge reichen, um die Fans mitzunehmen. Also es ist nicht so, dass dieser fränkische Pessimismus auch immer wieder von den Verantwortlichen, diesem Verein und seinem Umfeld unterstellt wird. Ich glaube, der ist nicht so ausgeprägt, sondern es ist tatsächlich so, dass einfach viel zu oft grottiger Sport angeboten wird. Und wenn sich da dann ein bisschen was ändert, dann ist sofort sehr viel Begeisterungsfähigkeit da.
Hat man ja vielleicht auch im DFB-Pokalfviertelfinale gegen den VfB Stuttgart gemerkt, was ja ein knappes Spiel war und wo man beiden Fans sehen – also die Stuttgarter sind ja quasi in einer ähnlichen Situation nur eine Etage weiter oben – da hat man beiden Fans sehen angemerkt, diesen Willen oder diesen Wunsch danach wenigstens in der Pokalsaison noch träumen zu dürfen, wenn schon ansonsten der Alltag eher trist ist.
Ja, genau. So war es, auch wenn dieses Spiel nicht wirklich knapp war. Also das war so ein typisches schlechter Erstligist, trifft auf noch schlechteren Zweitligisten und hat alles unter Kontrolle. Muss halt bloß irgendwann mal ein Tor schießen und läuft nie Gefahr, selbst ein Tor zu kassieren. Also das war ja gut.
Da kam der Trainerwechsel zu früh beim VfB, sage ich mal.
Aber es hat Nürnberg mal wieder gut getan, so einen Ausverkauf des Stadions zu erleben. Das war ganz gut für die Seele, auch wenn es dann schlecht ausgegangen ist. Aber ja, die große Gefahr liegt in der Liga.
Also als wir das letzte Mal hier über den Club länger gesprochen haben, da haben wir auch über den Kader gesprochen. Und da haben wir damals noch gesprochen, dass man mit Dua und daferner dachte, man hätte so die fehlenden Pusseteile geholt. Das aber so eins der Probleme war, dass im defensiven Mittelfeld jemand fehlt, der das Spiel ordnet. Das war allerdings damals auch noch sehr von der damaligen Trainer-Idee her gedacht. Wie würdest du denn jetzt mit – jetzt haben wir Hacking-Fiel-Fußball gesehen, wobei der, glaube ich, eher pragmatisch ist. Man muss jetzt halt einfach irgendwie Punkte sammeln. Also um Spielphilosophie und so geht es da nicht. Aber wie blickst du denn jetzt auf den Kader? Wo sind da die Baustellen?
Überall. Also man muss – tatsächlich wollen Fiel und Hacking-Fußball spielen. Also es ist schon eine neue Idee dahinter. Man muss auch einschränkend sagen, dass der Klub wirklich viel Verletzungspech hatte in dieser Saison. Also ich glaube, als ich jetzt Jan Czammra verletzt hat, war es dann die zwölfte Operation in dieser Saison. Also wirklich, wirklich viel, was auch immer wieder die Außenverteidiger-Positionen betroffen hat. Es gibt jetzt einen defensiven Mittelfeldspieler, der sein Handwerk einigermaßen versteht. Das ist Florian Flick, der ausgeliehen ist bis zum Saisonende. Rauskristallisiert hat sich jetzt das wirklich das größte Problem, die Offensive, die Torgefährlichkeit. Du triffst zwar einigermaßen regelmäßig, du stehst jetzt bei zehn Treffern, arbeitest aber während des Spiels nicht so viel, dass alle vollends von ihm begeistert sind, weshalb er jetzt auch zweimal zu Beginn auf der Bank Platz nehmen musste. Ansonsten hat der Klub einfach riesen Probleme überhaupt in dieses letzte Drittel des Platzes zu kommen. Das war jetzt in Hannover erstaunlicherweise ein bisschen anders, das erste Mal. Da haben sie in der ersten Halbzeit tatsächlich viele Pässe in den Strafraum gebracht für ihre Verhältnisse, die haben dann aber die Chancen nicht verwertet. Aber ansonsten zieht sich das durch die Saison, dass zum Beispiel ein Mats Möller Daily, Lino Tempelmann, alles hoch veranlagte, hoch begabte Spieler es einfach nicht schaffen, die Stürmer so einzusetzen, wie man es bräuchte, um eine etwas sorgenfreiere Saison zu spielen.
Das heißt das Problem sind aber nicht diejenigen, die die Tore dann nicht schießen oder zu selten schießen, sondern dass sie zu selten die Gelegenheit bekommen, Tore zu schießen.
Ja, tatsächlich. In Hannover war es dann mal ausnahmsweise der, der die Tore schießen sollte, das Problem. Felix Lohkämper hat da von Beginn an gespielt und hatte drei ordentliche Möglichkeiten. Aber ansonsten ist das das große Problem des Klubs. Christopher Schindler, der Kapitän, hat gesagt, es ist alles nett und ordentlich, wie sie so bis 30 Meter vor dem Tor spielen.
Dann hat sich das Problem verschoben. Vor der Saison dachte man noch so, wer die Tore schießt. Das war in der Vorsaison die Problematik. Jetzt haben wir die herausgespiegten Chancen. Das ist letztlich auch, wenn man größer auf die Saison blickt, was man unter allen Trainern gesehen hat. Bei Robert Klaus war eines der Probleme, dass der Fußball – ich habe mir damals hier aufgeschrieben – nicht den attraktivsten Fußball spielen lassen. Das heißt, irgendeiner meiner Gäste hat gesagt, das war richtig scheiße. Dann habe ich das wahrscheinlich so hier transkribiert. Also jetzt quasi von der Offensiv-Idee her. Unter Markus Weinzehr habe ich ehrlich gesagt nicht so viele Spiele vom Club mitverfolgen wollen, weil ich habe genügend Weinzehr-Fußball in meinem Leben gesehen.
Genau, da gab es dann einfach keine Idee mehr. Das war vollkommen richtig. Ich musste mir die Spiele alle angucken. Und diese Zeit meines Lebens gibt mir niemand mehr zurück. Aber da war dann gar keine Idee mehr. Robert Klaus, dass er nicht den attraktivsten Fußball spielt, das wusste man aus den vorangegangenen beiden Saisons. Dieter Hecking war der Meinung. Es geht mit dieser Mannschaft, er hat auch in Hannover noch mal gesagt, diese Mannschaft ist dafür zusammengestellt, dass er Fußball spielt, warum man dann Markus Weinzehr holt. Auch so eine Frage, die man die Hecking sich oder die Mann Hecking nach der Saison spätestens stellen darf. Aber ja, es gibt viele Probleme.
Vor allem sind es so Probleme, also wenn Probleme sich immer wieder wiederholen, dann hat es ja oft auch mit der dahinterstehenden Strategie zu tun und hängt dann vielleicht gar nicht immer nur an Einzelpersonen. Tue ich Dieter Hecking und vielleicht auch Olaf Rebbe unrecht, wenn ich sage, sie sind eigentlich diejenigen, die die Strategie vorgegeben haben, oder ist eben genau das, womit wir dann eigentlich an den Anfang des Gesprächs zurückkommen, das Ding, das man sagen muss, wenn man jetzt mal die größeren Linien anguckt, dann stimmt die Ausrichtung des Vereins nicht.
Ja, natürlich, die stimmt schon länger nicht mehr. Es fällt natürlich in Heckings Verantwortung, hängt aber auch damit zusammen, dass der 1. FC Nürnberg schon seit einiger Zeit nicht mehr wirklich viel Geld hat. Aber die strategische Neuausrichtung, die man sich von Hacking erwartet hat, die man sich von einem Sportvorstand erwartet, die ist halt ausgeblieben in diesen jetzt bald drei Jahren, die er hier gearbeitet hat. Das hat ganz gut angefangen mit Robert Claus, wurde so ein bisschen was aufgebaut. Und das hatten wir dann in großer Panik bei der ersten Möglichkeit wieder beendet. Ich sage nicht, dass Robert Claus noch Trainer sein müsste in Nürnberg, aber ich glaube, dieser Wechsel hat größtmögliche Panik ausgedrückt, von Claus auf Weinzehls, zumal Claus in den vergangenen beiden Spielzeiten immer mal wieder so Krisen hatte, die er dann überwunden hat. Und jetzt am Ende dieser Saison, wo man einfach sieht, egal welcher Trainer, die Mannschaft ist einfach nicht besser als da, wo sie im Moment steht. Es sind jetzt, glaube ich, noch fünf Punkte, die brauchen sie noch aus den letzten vier Spielen, um die Hinrundenbilanz nach Punkten auszugleichen. Also es ist wirklich absolut nichts besser geworden. Und genau diese fünf Punkte haben sie in den vier letzten Spielen der Hinrunde auch geholt. Also es ist sehr egal, wer diese Mannschaft trainiert, bis darauf, dass es jetzt ein bisschen besser ausschaut.
Ja, und gerade an Klaus hat man ja eben auch durch diese kritischen Phasen hinweg festgehalten. Also eigentlich war ja das Wohltuende, fand ich zumindest als neutraler Beobachtender, dass eben nicht gleich wieder der Trainer entlassen wurde bei der ersten Krise. Auch wenn ich jetzt auch, wenn ich die Spiele gesehen habe, jetzt selten mir Blumenketten vor Freude umgelegt habe, so ehrlich will ich auch sein, hat sich dann der Club vielleicht ein bisschen zu abhängig von Dieter Hecking gemacht? Ich meine, das ist jetzt so ein bisschen so eine ungerechte Frage, weil auf der einen Seite möchte man ja immer, dass jemand die Strategie vorgibt und dass dann auch quasi sich alles daran ausrichtet. Auf der anderen Seite, und da kennst du ja wahrscheinlich noch viel mehr Geschichten als ich, der es immer nur so vage am Rand wahrnimmt, konnte man schon manchmal das Gefühl haben, Dieter Hecking, mit dem ja der Club die letzte richtig erfolgreiche Zeit verbindet, ich denke, so kann man es glaube ich sagen, dem wurde dann auch einfach der rote Teppich ausgerollt und er durfte wirklich sehr, sehr viel tun. Und vielleicht muss man jetzt im Nachhinein feststellen, war vielleicht dann so in dem Ablauf nicht der Perfekt?
Ja, sicherlich. Aber Dieter Hecking kam in einer Phase, in der es dem Verein wirklich schlecht ging. Die Relegation gegen Ingolstadt war gerade vorüber ein großes, großes Chaos. Und Dieter Hecking sollte diesen Verein ein bisschen beruhigen, was man ihm zutrauen konnte, was er auch geschafft hat. Und dann ist es bei dem Konstrukt, wie der 1. FC Nürnberg funktioniert, dass es einen Aussichtsrat gibt, einen Ehrenamtlichen, der dann immer die Sportvorstände oder Finanzvorstände aussuchen muss. Ist es logisch, dass die Vorstände dann relativ viel Macht haben? Also das ist jetzt kein Alleinstellungsmerkmal von Hecking, sondern es ist einfach so in diesem Verein, dass es da keine andere Instanz gibt, die irgendwelche Richtungen vorgeben könnte. Und dann ist es eben die Aufgabe des Aussichtsrats, irgendwann mal zu sehen, ist derjenige, der die Richtung vorgibt, ist er noch der Richtige. Das wird das Spannende sein im Sommer.
Und hast du das Gefühl, dass man sich da schon für alle Szenarien vorbereitet? Also, dass man jetzt schon wüsste?
Nein. Es ist der 1. FC Nürnberg, deshalb.
Ja, ich will nicht immer diese Klischees bedienen, gerade weil ich aus der Ecke Nürnberg komme.
Ja, doch. Der 1. FC Nürnberg bedient diese Klischees relativ gut. Ich habe mich letztes Jahr mit jemandem unterhalten, auch im Zuge dieser Vertragsverlängerung von Dieter Hecking. Und da hieß es dann, wenn man den Vertrag jetzt nicht verlängert, dann müssten ja sozusagen alle Verhandlungen von vorne starten. Und deshalb verlängert man lieber den Vertrag. Also das war tatsächlich eine Argumentation von jemandem, der da ein bisschen Einsicht hat.
Vielleicht müsste ein bisschen mehr Strategie auch aus dem Aufsichtsrat kommen. Aber gut, dann werden wir das verfolgen. Jetzt erstmal die letzten Punkte sammeln. Wir haben ja schon angedeutet, es geht jetzt dann ins Heimspiel gegen den 1. FC Kaiserslautern. Man hat noch das Heimspiel gegen Rostock. Da irgendwo müssen die Punkte her. Denn ich denke, da wird ja Louis genauso drauf gucken wie ihr anderen. Gerade Hansa Rostock macht da unten gerade ein bisschen Stress. Das ist ja einer der Gründe, warum sie jetzt auch irgendwie die Vorhersage aus dem KDEP Podcast nochmal zurückgenommen werden wurde. Die haben jetzt zweimal gewonnen, Louis. Warum? Kannst du mir das erklären? Deswegen ging die Frage auch an dich.
Hat er ja schon in Sandhausen letztes Jahr mal mit einer sehr guten Rückrunde hinbekommen. Ich würde sagen, dass Louis Schwarz auf jeden Fall ein Trainer ist, der kurzfristig eine Mannschaft sehr stabilisieren kann. Dann ist halt sein Spielstil ein bisschen auf Effizienz angelegt. Viel Torchancen arbeiten sich seine Mannschaften meistens nicht. Aber wenn es dann so funktioniert wie gegen Kaiserslautern, dass dann der Schuss sitzt, dann gewinnt man eben 1-0. Irgendwann hat sich dann bei Sandhausen leider ein bisschen abgenutzt, würde ich sagen. Aber so kurzfristig würde ich Rostock auf jeden Fall nicht abschreiben. Man hat ja auch noch ein Direktasturier gegen Sandhausen. Die spielen ja gefühlt nochmal gegen alle, die da unten drin stehen. Genau. Was natürlich für Rostock ein großer Vorteil sein kann, aber auch ein Nachteil, wie immer mit dem Spielplan.
Die durchschnittliche Tabellenposition der letzten vier Gegner von Hansa Rostock ist 15, 5. Also, sie spielen aufgerundet gegen den Tabellensechzehnten. Zum Vergleich Bielefeld 8, 5, Regensburg 8, 5, Sandhausen 8, 5, aber auch Braunschweig 15, 5, die ja mit 32 Punkten auf Rang 14 liegen. Wenn wir uns mal so die Gesamtkonstellation angucken, bevor wir dann länger über den SVS sprechen. Louis, also Braunschweig 32, Rostock 31, Bielefeld 29 und dann Regensburg und Sandhausen 28. Das heißt, die letzten sechs oder fünf Teams innerhalb von vier Punkten. Kann noch alles passieren? Hast du da schon ein Gefühl, für was passieren wird?
Boah, ja, ich hoffe natürlich, dass Sandhausen da weiter macht, wo sie aufgehört haben. Aber es ist halt, es war ja auch letztes Mal in der letzten Episode schon so angeklungen, dass da unten irgendwie immer mal jemand eine kleine Serie starten kann. Dann gewinnt Braunschweig plötzlich gegen St. Pauli und wird dafür danach noch von Paderborn vermöbelt. Also so richtig einschätzen kann man das schwer. Ich würde natürlich sagen, Sandhausen hat jetzt noch zwei Schlüsselspiele gegen Braunschweig und gegen Rostock. Und wenn sie die beide gewinnen, dann ist man auf keinen Fall durch, weil dafür ist es da unten zu eng. Aber das wären schon mal zwei Big Points. Das erste hat man ja gegen Regensburg schon gewonnen. Und man hat ja lustigerweise exakt das gleiche Restprogramm wie Regensburg. Also man spielt beide Spiele noch gegen Rostock, gegen HSV, gegen Braunschweig und gegen Heidenheim nur in etwas anderer Reihenfolge. Also das wird echt noch spannend. Die einzigen, die da vielleicht noch so ein bisschen aus der Reihe springen, hast du ja schon gesagt, sind Bielefeld. Ich hatte ja eigentlich schon vollmundig Eva versprochen, dass Uwe Koschinath sie da retten wird, aber die letzten drei Spiele waren jetzt auch nicht mehr so rosig. Obwohl ich immer noch, hat sie richtig gesagt, großer Koschinath-Fan bin, wenn er nicht gerade wieder seine etwas speziellen Bilder von Männlichkeit an die Öffentlichkeit trägt. Also es wird auf jeden Fall spannend und ich werde hier auf keinen Fall irgendeine Prognose abgeben, die mich dann verfolgen wird bis zum nächsten Spieltag.
Ja, da bist du ganz Podcast-Profi, das merkt man direkt. Aber dann lass doch mal über Sandhausen sprechen. Den letzten Stichpunkt, den ich habe – ich mache mir immer bei diesen Kurzpassen immer viele Notizen, denn es ist schwierig, da den Überblick zu behalten. Und die letzte Notiz, die ich zum SV Sandhausen habe – ich weiß nicht, ob du es gesagt hast oder ein anderer Gast – das schwächste Team der Liga in fast allen Offensivstatistiken. Hat sich da was getan?
Also ich werde es auf jeden Fall nicht gewesen sein, weil ich hier zum ersten Mal endlich mal über Sandhausen reden darf. Ich habe hier Offensivstatistiken vor mir. Wenigste Expected Goals, viertwenigste Tore. Also immerhin hat man vier Tore mehr geschossen als man eigentlich hätte schießen sollen. Viertwenigste Kontertore, wenigste Abschlüsse, drittwenigste Großchancen, aber immerhin die beste Chancenverwertung. Also es bleibt dabei, die Offensivstatistiken sind ausbaufähig. Ich muss sagen, dass es unter Kleppinger schon nochmal ein bisschen zielstrebiger ausschaut nach vorne raus. Man hat ja auch schon nochmal deutlich umgestellt im Vergleich zu Oral und auch im Vergleich zu Schwarz, die jetzt beide eher klassisch 4-4-2 oder 4-2-3-1 gespielt haben. Unter Kleppinger spielt man jetzt wieder Fünferkette, was jetzt erstmal defensiver klingt, aber man verteidigt aktiver. Das heißt, es rückt immer mal wieder einer von den Halbverteidigern raus, vor allem Arne Sicker profitiert da so ein bisschen. Und der rennt dann auch gerne mal mit nach vorne, wenn es dann in den Konter reingeht. Also dahingehend ist man dann doch aktiver, trotz der vermeintlich defensiveren Grundordnung. Ein Offensivfeuerwerk ist es natürlich immer noch nicht, was man abfackelt.
Ja, und gleichzeitig haben wir jetzt gerade schon das Quiz vorweggenommen, das ich den Hörern und Hörern aufgeben wollte, nämlich nennen sie mir bitte alle drei Trainer, bzw. vier sind es ja dann sogar insgesamt, die auf der Trainerbank lagen. Bevor wir jetzt mal so über Restprogramme und was jetzt noch so vor dem SVS liegt sprechen, lass mal da so ein bisschen eine Bilanz ziehen. Also Alois Schwarz war bis Februar Trainer, dann kam Thomas Oral und er blieb nicht sehr lange, nämlich nur sechs Spiele, dann eben Gerhard Kleppinger und jetzt Oskar Carotano. Wie lässt sich das zusammenfassen, was da in den letzten Monaten beim SVS passiert ist?
Also Schwarz hatte ich ja schon ein bisschen anklingen lassen. Der hatte ja letztes Jahr noch in der Rückrunde – ich habe nachgeguckt – einen Punkt weniger geholt als Sandhausen bis zum 30. Spieltag in dieser Saison. Also 27 Punkte, war Fünfter in der Rückrundetabelle. Ich muss aber auch sagen, dass ich da schon im Vorlauf zu dieser Saison dachte, so wird es auf jeden Fall nicht weitergehen. Da musste man eigentlich auch zum Beispiel hier wieder die ominösen Expected Goals. Man hätte gemäß Expected Goals against 11 Tore mehr kassieren müssen, als man eigentlich kassiert hat. Da setzt dann auch, glaube ich, irgendwann die berühmte Regression zur Mitte ein, dass man irgendwann dann sich dem auch anpasst, wie es eigentlich aussehen sollte, ergebnistechnisch. Ich hatte trotzdem die Hoffnung, auch weil man da ja mit den Transfers auch so ein bisschen ein Statement gesetzt hat, vor allem mit David Kinzombie, dass man dann doch auch offensiv mehr Lösungen finden will. Da hat es dann vor allem daran gescheitert, dass man Test-Rot überhaupt nicht ersetzt bekommen hat. Also mit den verschiedenen Akteuren, die man da versucht hat, mit Pull-Crap, der jetzt auch keine 1 zu 1-Lösung war, der deutlich noch mal ein bisschen kleiner ist und eigentlich eher spielerischere Lösungen. Spielt momentan gar keine Rolle. Irgendwann hat man dann auch Adhemi geholt, der hat sich verletzt. Der spielt jetzt zum Glück wieder ein bisschen größere Rolle und kann auch zeigen, warum man ihn damals geholt hat. Irgendwann noch Al-Gadoui geholt, der auch nicht wirklich da Tritt gefasst hat. Also das war einmal so ein Problem. Dann ist die beste Defensive der Rückrunde eben zur schlechtesten von dieser Saison geworden. Also das, was eigentlich so das große Steckenpferd von Alois Schwarz ist, hat dann nicht mehr funktioniert. Man stand einfach nicht mehr so stabil. Zu Saisonbeginn war es immer alles sehr knapp. Ich glaube, man hat bis zum elften Spieltag jedes Spiel höchstens mit einem Torunterschied entweder gewonnen oder verloren. Ich hatte auch trotz Platz 18 nach der Hinrunde, weil es da einfach sehr, sehr knapp war noch unten drin, nicht so das richtig negative Gefühl, wie es vielleicht manche hatten, aber dann zum Rückrundenstart. Ich erinnere mich noch an eine PK von Alois Schwarz, wo er gefühlt sehr, sehr viele Floskeln rausgehauen hat, wo auch schon zur Winterpause so ein paar Register gezogen wurden, die normalerweise erst zu etwas, wenn es noch schlimmer aussieht, gezogen werden. Zum Beispiel, dass man einmal den Mannschaftsrat umgemodelt hat mit der Begründung, man wollte neue Akzente setzen. Und ich meine, gegen Bielefeld hat man dann ja gewonnen, war jetzt auch kein schlechter Auftritt, aber danach hat halt so eine absolute Negativ-Serie begonnen von, ich kann ja mal durchzählen, mit dem Pokalspiel gegen Freiburg, was eigentlich noch ganz positiv war, weil man da sehr lange noch die Null gehalten hat. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10 Spielen ohne Sieg. Da ist dann natürlich nochmal die Oral-Ära mit drin von sechs Spielen. Also da lief es dann lange nicht mehr so rund.
Ja, aber da lasse ich dich jetzt nicht so einfach so drüber weghudeln. Also, dass Alois Schwarz entlassen würde, das haben wir jetzt verstanden, was da die möglichen Gründe für gewesen sein könnten. Und dann kommt Thomas Oral. Und bevor ich hier drüber sprechen kann, was er verändert hat beim SVS, ist er schon wieder weg. War das jetzt mein Fehler? Hätte ich das wissen müssen? Hätte ich schneller diesen Schwerpunkt hier machen müssen?
Ich sage es mal so, ich bin ja, wie du schon gesagt hast, Fanradio-Reporter beim Hardewald Hörfunk, dem Fanradio der SV Sandhausen. Und ich habe kein einziges Spiel von Thomas Oral live begleiten dürfen, im Stadion gesehen oder als Reporter reportieren dürfen. Das heißt, es ging für mich auch ein bisschen zu schnell. Ich habe natürlich trotzdem Spiele von ihm gesehen. Er wurde wieder angekündigt, wie er so oft in solchen Phasen, als der Retter jemanden, der solche Phasen erlebt hat, Michael Kabacat, über den wir gleich auch nochmal reden müssen, der Sportdirektor kannte ihn auch noch aus gemeinsamer Zeit beim FSV Frankfurt. War auch so ein bisschen seine letzte Patrone, würde ich sagen. Und ist halt schon ziemlich in die Hose gegangen. Also ich muss sagen, die ersten zwei Spiele sahen gar nicht so schlecht aus. Also das Spiel gegen Nürnberg sah aus neutraler Sicht sehr schlecht aus, weil man sich es einfach nicht ansehen konnte bei Schneegestöber. Und ja, beide Mannschaften, ich glaube, es war auch das erste Spiel von Dieter Hecking dann als Trainer. Also war jetzt nicht das schönste Spiel anzuschauen, aber es war schon sehr eng und es hätte auch in eine andere Richtung laufen können vielleicht. Dann das Spiel gegen Kaiserslautern, da war ich auch mit so eins, zwei Schiri-Entscheidungen nicht hundertprozentig zufrieden, muss ich sagen. Die hätten auch in eine andere Richtung gehen können. Und da hat man eigentlich auch die oft zitierte Moral dann ja schon auch gezeigt. Aber dann waren dann halt auch so Auftritte dabei wie gegen St. Pauli und vor allem und dann auch gegen Fürth, die, glaube ich, dann letztlich Thomas Oral nicht mehr haltbar gemacht haben. Gegen St. Pauli sind, glaube ich, die Fans zur Halbzeit rausgelaufen. Gegen Fürth hat jetzt Michi schon im Vorgespräch angesprochen. Gab es dann nach dem Spiel, wurde die Mannschaft nochmal zum Rapport gerufen, nachdem sie nicht in die Kurve kam. Da gab es auch vom Präsidenten Zustimmung für die Fans und meinte, dass es komplett nachvollziehbar ist, dass sie wütend sind. Vor allem, wenn die Mannschaft nach so einem Spiel dann nicht in die Kurve kommt. Hat mich auch jetzt, ohne zu viel über meinen anderen abstiegsbedrohten Dorfverein zu reden, aber bei Hoffenheim gab es eine ähnliche Szene, wo die Fans den Mannschaft am Trainingsgelände nach dem Mainz-Spiel empfangen haben. Und danach lief es auch wieder besser. Und so ähnlich war es bei Sandhausen, nur war dann auch der Trainer danach weg. Alles in allem würde ich sagen, dass Ora – also er hat versucht, ein bisschen offensiver ranzugehen, ein höheres Pressing. Aber insgesamt gab es jetzt keine riesigen Änderungen. Und man hat auch irgendwann das Gefühl gehabt, dass er ein bisschen resigniert. Am Anfang hat er versucht, Optimismus auszustrahlen. Gemeint, wir müssen Spaß haben bei unserer Aufgabe. Ja, hat man dann irgendwann nicht mehr gespürt. Und irgendwann war es auch so eine gewisse Ratlosigkeit. Ich habe jetzt nicht genau erkannt, was er wirklich vorhat mit dem Team. Und der Feuerwehrmann, der dann sein sollte, war er eben auch nicht. Ich glaube, er ist jetzt der schlechteste 2-Liga-Trainer der SVS-Geschichte. Mit 6 Spielen, 2 unentschieden, 4 Niederlagen.
Und dann die verbleibenden zwei? Wir haben ja vier Trainer auf der Bank erlebt.
Ja, Oskar Korochano und Gerhard Kleppinger. Wobei eigentlich Gerhard Kleppinger mehr der Chef-Trainer ist. Korochano ist also sein Co-Trainer. Jetzt hat er noch Ralf Scharinger geholt vom Badischen Fußballverband. Lustigerweise macht er das Ganze jetzt bis Saisonende ehrenamtlich. Es bleibt auch parallel noch Verbandstrainer. Als er angekündigt wurde, habe ich dann mal nachgeforscht, wie man das so macht auf transfermarkt.de. Und er hat schon mal den SVS trainiert. Vor genau zehn Jahren war er erst Spieler. Und dann wurde irgendwann der Trainer entlassen. Und er war so kurz vorm Karriereende. Dann hat er noch so anderthalb Jahre mal kurz ein bisschen Trainer gemacht. Ab und an auch selbst noch die Schuhe geschnürt. Aber war dann eher Trainer. Also ja, ist nicht zum ersten Mal beim SVS. Gerhard Kleppinger kennt ihn noch aus der Traditionsmannschaft vom Karlsruher SC. Also auch hier hat man gute Kontakte gehabt, um schnell noch jemanden dran zu holen. Und es ist ja auch nicht das erste Mal, dass Gerhard Kleppinger zur Saisonende dann übernehmen darf. Vor zwei Jahren hat er das ja schon zusammen mit Kulowits gerettet, durfte dann auch die neue Saison gehen. Das hat dann nicht mehr so gut funktioniert. Und dann kam ja Alois Schwarz, also Kleppo. Man sieht auf jeden Fall, dass er die Mannschaft sehr gut kennt. Der ist ja auch immer noch Scouting-Chef in Sandhausen. Hat auch einen extrem guten Draht zur Mannschaft. Und man hat eigentlich vom ersten Spiel angesehen, was er eben vorhat, gegen Magdeburg – Magdeburg, wurde mir von Eva gesagt, soll ich sagen. Korrekt. Hat er eben auf diese Fünferkette umgestellt. Und es hat halt super funktioniert, gerade weil die Magdeburger so variabel spielen. Hat einfach das Übergeben super geklappt. Man hat die immer sehr gut gestört, auch im Spielaufbau, der dort auch oft riskant ist. Daraus ist dann die Standardsituation entstanden, die zum 1-0 geführt hat. Ich hatte sogar noch im Spiel gesagt, dass Magdeburg gerne mal im Spielaufbau Bälle verliert. Und ich glaube, zehn Sekunden später war er dann auch weg. Und dann kam die Ecke und dann kam es 1-0. Also das hat super geklappt. Man ist dann auch deutlich variabler, habe ich das Gefühl. Zum Beispiel gegen Paderborn, wo man ja schon zur Halbzeit eigentlich, wo das Spiel eigentlich schon vorbei sein könnte. Und dann stellt man zur Halbzeit um auf 4-3-3. Und plötzlich ist es ein ganz anderes Spiel. Du hast auf dem ganzen Platz 1 gegen 1-Situationen. Läufst vorne mit drei Spitzen an und setzt dich unter Druck. Und dann fällt plötzlich 2-2. Und ja, ich würde nicht sagen, das wäre ein Sieg drin gewesen. Der wäre wahrscheinlich nicht verdient gewesen. Und man hat auch einfach ein ganz anderes Selbstbewusstsein, weil vorher hätte man – ich habe es ja vorhin angeklinken lassen – drei Jahre hat es gedauert, dass man mal nach 2 Tore Rückstand wieder zurückkommt. Ja, das ist auch Clapping als Verdienst. Und man sieht auch so ein bisschen, dass er seinem System auch alles unterordnet, daran, dass die Kinsombi-Brüder plötzlich – David Kinsombi – zwei Spiele auf der Tribüne sitzt, als eigentlich der Top-Neuzugang im Sommer gekommen. Und jetzt dann auch unter Schwarz in den Mannschaftsrat befördert worden. Seinen Bruder auch erstmal noch auf der Bankplatz nehmen müssen, einfach weil für ihn als Außenbahn-Spieler in diesem 5-3-2 nicht dringend Platz war. Und dann kommt er aber gegen Paderborn rein und sorgt gleich komplett für Feuer auf dem Platz, hat gleich zwei echt gute Aktionen. Was auch sehr wichtig war, weil das Mervey Papela jetzt zurück ist, der hatte so ein Dysmosebandriss und kam dann sogar zum Fürth-Spiel zurück. So das einzig Positive, was ich aus diesem Fürth-Spiel mitnehmen würde. Und der zeigt einfach, der ist ja auch eine Leihgabe von Mainz 05 und ich glaube, der könnte auch bei Mainz nächstes Jahr eine okaye Rolle spielen. Vielleicht nicht als Stammspieler, aber was der da an Stabilität im Mittelfeld gibt. Und er ist jetzt ja auch nicht der Größte, aber er ist absoluter Staubsauger vor der Abwehr und ist auch im Zweikämpfen meistens ganz stabil, trotz seiner Schmächtigkeit. Und auch mit Abu-Bekir El-Zeyn, der ja erst im Sommer von BVB 2 kam, hat man jetzt einen echt aufgebaut, der auch dann unter Oral schon etwas größere Rolle gespielt hat, aber jetzt dann auch leistungsmäßig echt seinen Herz auf den Platz lässt. Also nach dem Magdeburg-Spiel und auch noch nach dem Paderborn-Spiel war der so fertig, weil er so viel gerannt ist, er hätte auch gegen Magdeburg schon die Vorentscheidung besorgen können. Da sind ihm glaube ich auch ein bisschen die Kräfte ausgegangen, dann Freistehen vom Keeper, würde ich ihm aber dann auch nicht mehr vorwerfen.
Aber das heißt quasi, wenn du jetzt dann Neuzugänge nennst, die jetzt eine gute Phase haben und mit dazu beigetragen haben, also das habe ich ja noch gar nicht gesagt, aus den letzten drei Spielen 7 Punkte geholt, Sandhausen. Zweimal gewonnen, einmal unentschieden. Das ist ja das, was überhaupt Sandhausen noch da unten mit drin hält. Ansonsten die anderen, wir haben ja unter anderem über Rostock gesprochen, die wären jetzt schon viel, viel weiter weg. Also wenn das Neuzugänge sind und gleichzeitig du mir sagst, der jetzige Trainer ist der Scouting-Chef, dann wirkt das ja so, als ob Kleppinger vor allem erstmal die vorhandenen Spieler offenbar ein bisschen besser einsetzt. Kann das sein?
Also ich glaube, er hat auf jeden Fall schon mal einen absoluten Plan, was er mit der Mannschaft anstellen will. Und das sind auch nicht nur zwingend Neuzugänge, sondern so jemand wie Arne Sicker, der schon in der Winterpause gehen sollte eigentlich. Und der aber auch schon in der ersten Amtszeit unter Kleppinger einer der war, die eher gesetzt waren, weil er einfach weiß, was er an ihm hat. Also Arne Sicker ist jetzt kein absolut begnadeter Techniker, aber der macht dahinten halt seinen Job. Und der ist auch sehr flexibel einsetzbar. Der ist ja eigentlich Linksverteidiger, spielt jetzt diesen linken Part in der Dreierkette und macht das einfach sehr, sehr gut, sehr stabil. Und ja, da sieht man halt bei Kleppinger die viel zitierte Erfahrung und einfach, dass er diesen Verein halt in- und auswendig kennt. Und ja, ich glaube, das ist schon ein sehr großer Faktor. Und der andere ist, dass er eben auch einfach, ich glaube, da schon nochmal ein bisschen eine neue, neues Selbstbewusstsein entfacht hat. Was natürlich auch mit den Punkten kommt, aber auch gegen Magdeburg war das von Beginn an ein ganz anderer Auftritt. Man war viel enger dran in den ganzen Zweikämpfen. Man ist jeden Fall hinterhergejagt. Auch das Gegenpressing war viel besser. Also da hat er auch schon noch einiges bewirkt.
Gut, also das ist die Trainerposition. Prognose, da bist du zu erfahren, gibst du nicht ab, ob das für Sandhausen klappt. Dann haben wir jetzt aber noch ein letztes Thema, denn während wir hier aufgezeichnet haben, hat der SVS bekannt gegeben, dass man einen neuen Sportdirektor hat, aber noch nicht verraten will, wer es ist, weil man The Mask Sportdirektor anscheinend jetzt spielen möchte, mit der Öffentlichkeit.
Ja, der sollte eigentlich ja schon vor zwei Wochen da sein. Also man hatte ja quasi wenige, ich glaube zwei Tage nach der Entlassung von Thomas Ural, war dann auch Mikael Kabacza nach fast vier Jahren als sportlicher Leiter weg. Und man hatte dann angekündigt, in den nächsten acht Tagen soll der neue Sportdirektor kommen. Jetzt hat es halt nochmal zwei Wochen länger gedauert, aber immerhin ist er jetzt da. Man will ihn unter anderem nicht kommunizieren, weil er offenbar noch bei einem anderen Klub vertraglich gebunden ist. Genau, was natürlich die Planung auch ein bisschen erschwert. Man hatte eigentlich gesagt, man möchte möglichst frühzeitig eben diese Personalien geklärt haben, damit man eben auch rechtzeitig mit der Planung für die kommende Saison beginnen kann. Sandhausen hat jetzt auch kein monströses Personal. Also man hat den Präsidenten Jürgen Machmeier und man hat den Geschäftsführer Volker Piekser. Und dann gäb es einen Scouting-Chef, der gerade noch nebenberuflich Trainer ist. Und ja, also viel mehr wäre da gar nicht mehr so da. Also man hat natürlich einen Team-Manager mit Klingmann und auch Tim Kister, der gerade noch keine, ich weiß nicht, ob er eine offizielle Funktion im Verein hat. Ich glaube, er hospitiert gerade viel. Der macht gerade auch so eine Sport-Manager-Ausbildung. Aber es braucht halt jetzt irgendeinen Kaderplaner, der sowohl für eine mögliche dritte Liga einen Plan hat, als auch für die zweite Liga. Ich hoffe da mal, dass man den neuen Mann, den man jetzt noch nicht kommunizieren möchte, möglichst auch frühzeitig einbinden kann. Offiziell ist er ab 1. Juli da. Das ist halt, ich glaube, vier Wochen vor Saisonbeginn. Da sollte vorher schon einiges geschehen. Gerade wenn es in die dritte Liga gehen sollte, da hat man drei Verträge, die in der Liga gültig sind. Wurde von Volker Piegser verraten. Da würde also einiges anfallen. Wäre natürlich optimal, wenn man da dann sich gar nicht mehr mit beschäftigen muss. Aber es wäre natürlich naiv, wenn man nicht auch für die dritte Liga mitplanen würde. Ich glaube schon, dass es konsequent wäre, Kabacca zu entlassen. Er hat auch schon sehr viel Kritik abbekommen, vor allem aus Fan-Kreisen. Ich weiß doch, hinter uns sitzen immer so ein paar Mecker-Opis bei uns auf der Medientribüne. Die rufen gefühlt seit zwei Jahren Kabacca raus.
Da muss man einfach Alex Zorninger kommen und den zeigen. Kannst du dir mal vorbeischicken, dass er für Ruhe sorgt?
Die offizielle Kritik von Machmeier war auf jeden Fall, dass man so ein bisschen seine DNA verloren habe. Man hat zu viele große Namen eingekauft. Ich meine, viele haben auch funktioniert. Diegmeier ist nicht nur image-technisch, sondern auch leistungsmäßig. Außer, dass er zuletzt sehr viel verletzt war. Aber davor war es ja schon stark.
Der ist beim SVS zum Meme geworden.
Ich durfte alle seine beiden Zweitligatore, die ersten beiden live miterleben und das erste sogar selbst reportieren.
Das wird mal Trivia zu deiner Person. Wenn du mal ein ganz alter Sportjournalist bist und man dann quasi einen Fußball-Quiz rund spricht, was kennzeichnet den frühen Löser? Dann ist das die Antwort.
Einmal das und dass ich vor allen Dingen bei diesem Tor erst gar nicht gerafft habe, dass es Dennis Diekmeier war, weil es mich so verwehrt hat. Aber ich hatte noch den Pakt parat, dass es sein erstes Profitor war. Das muss man dann aber auch wissen als Reporter. Also einmal die Geschichte, dass man eben viel nach Namen eingekauft hat. Also wenn man da jemanden voranstellen will, dann zum Beispiel Diego Contendo, der halt null Komma gar nicht funktioniert hat. Und dann die andere Sache, dass einfach die Mannschaft wenig harmoniert hat. Ich meine, einerseits war es auch ein Kunststück von Carpaccia, dass er gefühlt jedes Jahr einmal den halben Kader umgeschmissen hat. Und es hat trotzdem irgendwie funktioniert. Ich glaube, letztes Jahr 24 Neuzugänge, 24 Abgänge.
Und das ja immer für wenig Geld.
Also so ziemlich alle immer ablösefrei. Dieses Jahr waren es nur 13 Neuzugänge, 14 Abgänge. Nur in Anführungszeichen. Also das größte Problem hatte ich ja vorhin schon angesprochen, dass es keinen Nachfolger für Testroth gefunden wurde, der dem Ruf des Geldes nach Ingolstadt gefolgt ist. Aber ja, insgesamt hat man einfach nichts Gefühl gehabt, dass der Kader super ausgewogen ist. Vielleicht hatte dann am Ende Kleppinger auch mehr Idee, was er damit anfangen soll als die anderen Trainer. Man weiß es nicht. Und andererseits kann man natürlich auch, ich glaube, was ihm am Ende das Genick gebrochen hat, war wirklich Thomas Oral, die Verpflichtung, der ja wie gesagt sein Mann war. Sie kannten sich schon, ich glaube, sogar zusammengespielt beim FSV Frankfurt, wo dann Kabacca später auch Teammanager war. Und der hat ja überhaupt nicht funktioniert. Und es war jetzt auch nicht das erste Mal, dass ein Trainer von ihm nicht super geklappt hat. Michael Schiele, wenn ich da zurückdenke. Im Braunschweig scheint es ja ganz okay zu laufen. Hat sie ja auch zurück in die 2. Liga geführt. In Sandhausen hat es überhaupt nicht funktioniert. Auch mit, ich glaube, allein mit seiner Art. Er hat einfach nicht geschafft, irgendwie in dieser Mannschaft Autorität auszustrahlen und irgendwie die Mannschaft hinter seiner Mission zu vereinen. Ich glaube, taktisch ist das ein überragender Trainer, aber er hat einfach null nach Sandhausen gepasst. Und gerade ihn dann als Nachfolger für Koshina zu holen, der in Sandhausen wirklich ein hohes Ansehen hatte und eigentlich ja schon einen einstelligen Tabellenplatz als Ziel ausgegeben hatte damals, war dann insgesamt…
Der letzte Tropfen der Berühmte. Also wir sehen, es ist viel passiert beim SVS, so wie ja auch beim Club und beim Kleeblatt. Also ich kann mir ganz entspannt angucken, wie jetzt die Saison läuft. Je nach Tabellensituation werdet ihr das ein bisschen angespannter tun. Aber es gibt ja auch noch in zwei Wochen die nächste Sendung zur 2. Liga und zumindest ist aktuell der Plan, es wird auch noch mal einen größeren Rückblick geben dann nach der Saison. Jetzt erstmal möchte ich mich aber bei euch dreien bedanken, dass ihr euch die Zeit genommen habt für den Rasenfunk. Ich danke Fadi Keblawi, dem Ed Gopenghurst. Folgt ihm auf Twitter, es ist ein Spektakel. Danke dir, lieber Fadi. Dann danke ich Michi Fischer, dem Ed Flachpass unterstrich auf Twitter. Michi, es ist immer eine Freude dich hier zu haben. Und herzlichen Dank auch an Louis Loeser, der jetzt endlich auch mal über Sandhausen sprechen durfte. Sorry, Louis, das war mir nicht so klar. Du bist bei der TSG bei mir immer gesetzt, bei Sandhausen eigentlich auch. Mit wem habe ich denn ansonsten über Sandhausen gesprochen? Ich bin gerade ehrlich verwirrt. Aber schön, dass du hier warst.
Sehr gerne. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob du jemals mit irgendwem dezidiert über Sandhausen bist.
Kann das wirklich sein?
Sonst empfehle ich immer den Kollegen von Carpe Diem. Der macht das auch super.
Ja, es gibt diese Schwerpunktkonzeption für den Zweitliga-Kurzpass. Das gibt es ja noch nicht so lange. Wahrscheinlich liegt es da drin.
Ich glaube auch. Und wer mich länger über Sandhausen reden will, der darf gerne am letzten Spieltag, wenn dann der HSV sich in die Relegation schießt, und Sandhausen vielleicht auch in die Relegation oder darüber hinaus zuhören, dann darf ich den hoffentlich nicht einen Hamburger Platzsturm reportieren. Ich finde, Nürnberg und Hannover sollten die einzigen Mannschaften bleiben, die in Sandhausen einmal den Platz umgemäht und das Ortsschild geklaut haben.
Hier, dann hört ihr den Hartwald Hörfunk, der ist dann eure richtige Adresse. In diesem Sinne, lieben Dank euch dreien und danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Danke, dass ihr mit dabei wart. Und wie gesagt, nochmal der Hinweis, bitte unterstützt den Rasenfunk finanziell. Es ist gut angelegtes Geld. Ich verspreche davon, mir keinen Pool zu kaufen. Das ist nicht in das Plan der ganzen Unterstützung. Also, es geht hier dann auch bald weiter. Wir machen natürlich als nächstes Männer-Bundesliga, Frauen-Bundesliga kommt dann auch hier im Kurzpass und es erscheint bald ein Tribüngespräch. Darauf könnt ihr gespannt sein. Macht's gut, bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk.